[Music]
hi guys you wouldn't believe what just
happened um it's the 13th I flew on uh
seat 13A in the aircraft and my computer
just crashed 5 minutes ago and it's just
rebooted so that's why I'm getting
updates over
there uh I'm in control is everybody
having fun at CSS C so far wo has
everyone has anyone learned something
new
today oh that's good okay uh we're going
to go and learn some other new stuff
today uh my name is rosan and I work uh
in a team at Adobe called Web platform
and a lot of my teammates work on web
standards and implementation of CSS
features in browsers such as webkit
Chrome and uh Firefox now part of my job
is to play with all of The Cutting Edge
CSS features they built to figure out
how they work in the browser how they
work with various other features and to
come up with new use cases for them now
as you can imagine it's a pretty fun job
because I because I get to live on The
Cutting Edge uh daily and it's also a
very frustrating job because if
something happens to go wrong the answer
usually is not simple and there's no
stack Overflow thread that I can
check but today I want to talk about the
excitement around this stuff today I
want to go through some uh new features
coming to CSS that deal with layout and
Graphics now I have a lot of code
samples and a lot of demos to go through
and barely enough time to do it so I'm
just going to jump right in to CSS
regions regions is a uh feature that
was invented to bridge the gap between
layout done in traditional print
magazines and something which was not
possible in print in digital publishing
so in newspapers you're used to having a
layout with content flowing
from oh my God my computer is still
starting sorry about that so newspapers
have content that which goes from one
box to another uh and from one page to
the other and this was missing from the
web on the web you usually have one slab
of content and you scroll through it to
get to more um text so CSS regions
essentially is a feature that allows you
to control where content goes on your
page and what happens to that content
when it doesn't fit into a box so for
example you could use CSS regions to
flow content into another element rather
than hide it or scroll
it and because we're dealing with
digital publishing we want to float that
content wherever we want on the page
much the same way we want the same
flexibility that traditional print
designers have CSS regions work in a
two-step mechanism so let me bump up the
font size for a second
if I hope everybody can see this so in
the first step we use a selector to
collect some content into What's called
the name flow we use the flow into
property and we're basically telling the
browser look I want you to keep a hold
of this content and keep it in this
bucket which I called my flow CU I want
to work with it at this point the
content does not render on the page
anymore it's like you would use display
none on it it's still there in the Dom
but you don't see
it the important part is step number two
where you actually control how to show
the content and you use a selector again
you pick some elements and you make them
pull the content from the name flow this
is turning those elements into regions
and the content will start flowing into
the first region what did not fit into
the first region will go into the second
region and in the third region and so
forth until all of the content from that
name flow has completely appeared on the
page the main advantage here is that
these region these elements can be
whichever shape or size you want them to
be and they can be anywhere in the Dom
is everybody with me on this one here's
an illustration of how this actually
works so we have our flow collected uh
in one place and we have our Elements
which are going to be turned into
regions and they're positioned uh across
the screen and have different sizes and
when we marry the two together we get
our content appearing in the outline or
in the in the shape of the regions we
have
used but enough with the pretty pictures
let me show you some
demos if the demo gods are going to be
with me
today so the first one I have is a um a
concept of a digital publication so over
here I have uh one page of content which
is going to a second one and possibly to
a third one if it doesn't fit and all of
this text is flowing through regions so
this text over here is going to go to
the second one and all the content that
did not fit here is going to go to the
second page so let me just select some
text and resize the page so you can see
what's going on over here so as we do
that you're going to see my Spotify
window in the back but what's more
important is the um is the content
that's being flown between regions over
here so as I go to the second page we're
we're going to see that content move
across from one box to the other now I'm
sorry but my Spotify is private so I'd
rather quit that one before anybody sees
my music
preferences okay so this is um a concept
of digital publishing which Echoes back
to traditional print but I want to show
you a Different Twist to this one here's
a demo that we did with content from
National Geographic and it's a story
about orphan baby elephants and yeah I
know it's sad
a before I tell you how this demo works
I'm going to scroll through some of the
the content so you see some of the text
some of the pictures yeah uh so it's a
neatly designed uh article
and if you've been paying very close
attention you've seen that the amount of
text and the amount of picture occupies
exactly one viewport height and that's
not by accident this is using CSS
regions to flow content between um
regions that are are using viewport
height units now for those of you who
don't know what those are are basically
a way of defining something which is
100% of the viewport and only the
viewport can Define that um that that
size so as we have this content over
here and we resize the page the content
is going to slowly disappear and it's
going to appear beneath this Photograph
over here and this is a very neat thing
to do especially on mobile devices when
scrolling is not very uh precise so
you're less likely to lose your place
when you're reading because all of the
text fits within one viewport and you
have a picture right after it so it it
gets difficult to lose your
place okay going back to uh regions we
kind of figured out by this point that
it does the job that we want it to do it
can do digital publishing like you do a
traditional publishing but a very
important side effect we noticed and it
was this was unexpected but really
valuable is that what we're achieving
here is markup separation because of the
two-step flow that makes regions work we
content we collect content from one
place and we inject it into another we
can separate our semantic markup from
our layout markup the one we have to use
every now and then to make things look
just right so we can essentially use CSS
regions to inject our content which B
into something which resembles HTML
templates now if you're not very
comfortable with doing uh decorators in
Shadow Dom maybe this is something the
to pick your interest of course this
opens up a lot of new possibilities for
responsive design and I'm going to show
you one of
them
so
this is uh a rough sketch of a web
application that you would possibly have
uh on the web so you have some buttons
uh in the header and then you have some
links in the footer and your content in
the middle now to do this responsively
to adapt to a phone um size or or a
small
screen a common design pattern is to
group all of the non-essential
navigation uh uh controls into a menu
that slides to the side but that's
difficult to do with the features we
currently have because these elements
are in different Dom order positions and
you can't really rip them out and put
them into a single element however if we
were to use CSS regions we could do
something like this so notice the
elements at the top and the elements in
the footer and as I resize this page I
can collect all of those elements and I
can float them into a menu which is in
off view so when I resize back I get my
other
layout uh the uh the full size layout
I'll just jump into the code really
quickly to show you what's happening
here so I have this aside ID menu over
here let me bump up the phont size just
a little bit and at a
specific um media query when I get
really really small you can see this is
going to consume the content from the
name flow called controls now I'm
generating this name flow at the
specific media query and I'm collecting
all of those elements and putting them
into the side
menu pretty neat stuff because this adds
a lot more options to when you want to
do uh responsive design with the tools
you already have and something that's
really important here is that regions
are only visual containers so any event
handlers you would have attached or any
styling you have on those elements they
they will still work regions just
position them visually into some other
place they still live in their original
Dom
positions is that cool yeah thought
so thank
you CSS regions is being implemented in
webkit and Google Chrome and of course
in the Opera version that uses the blink
uh engine and there's also a partial
implementation starting with inter
Explorer 10 which is using an older
version of the
spec okay going forward to CSS blending
this is part of a bigger spec called uh
blending and compositing now compositing
is the graphical operation that the
browser does to merge two shapes or two
elements into a single shape blending on
the other hand is the graphical
operation of mixing the color values and
and the transparency values of the two
elements being
composited it's a bit tricky to explain
without Graphics but I have some pretty
pictures so up until now browsers have
given us simple Alpha compositing we
have an example here of multiple
backgrounds and I'm using a uh linear
gradient and I'm putting underneath it a
uh picture so with simple Alpha
compositing we have we where you have
the semi-transparent gradient you get
the effect uh on the left which is
basically a way for the browser to tell
you this is what I could do for you now
with blend modes we can convince the
browser to give us something more
Instagram is like this so this is using
a background blend Mode called
overlay I guess the uh the effect is
instantly visible but how do these uh
background blend modes work well they're
essentially a mathematic iCal function
in which um the browser takes the color
value uh and the alpha value of uh a
pixel and it runs them through an
operation with the alpha value and the
color value of another picture in this
case we have a source and a backdrop and
the result you get through that
mathematical function is the Blended
result so let's just jump quickly into
code here I'm going to use the uh web
inspector again again so this is where
I'm trying to blend a background image
from the source with a background color
and as I change the
color of uh of the background the result
of the Blended result instantly changes
and this is just using a
hardlight um blend mode over here we can
choose for example multiply which is
going to give us um a different result
or we can try screen and we get a much
lighter result so this is essentially
allowing us to build textures on the fly
with multiple backgrounds right into the
browser there are a lot of blend modes
to choose from and each of them will
have slightly different results
depending on the input images you give
them uh I definitely encourage you to
try them out and figure out which works
best for you but so far we've only been
speaking uh about background blend modes
because honestly is one it's one of the
few things that's implemented in a
browser a very cool thing that's coming
up next is element blending the
possibility of blending different
elements together for example you can
have some paragraph text and a
background texturized image and when you
mix blend the two you get this lovely
texturized text effect without having to
go to an external program to generate
new images now this opens up a lot of
possibilities for doing customization to
your designs and I'm pretty excited
about this one I can't wait to play with
with uh element blending in terms of
implementation I've shaded all of the
browsers partially out because all of
them have partial implementations there
are background blend modes element blend
modes and canvas blend modes and each of
these browsers have
part of the implementation which is
ongoing let's talk about shapes we have
shapes in CSS we have
rectangles we have tall
rectangles we have
squares small
squares tiny squares yeah I guess you
know where this is all going into we
also have rounded rectangles
because we have border radius we have
tall rounded
rectangles and if you push the Border
radius far enough you get a circle but
deep deep down inside of its heart it
still knows it's a
square
okay maybe I'm poking too much fun at
CSS there's this collection of shapes of
CSS on CSS tricks where people have
used
um different features
uh different quirks of features to
generate uh shapes in CSS so we have our
squares we have the rectangle again
Circle ovals this is somebody who's
using borders to generate triangles and
it goes on these are pretty creative
uses of features my favorite one is the
uh Space Invaders over
here this is this is super cool
somebody's using multiple box Shadows to
generate the space invader shape
now I do have a lot of respect for these
guys because they're using their
creative skill to generate shapes but
unfortunately these are not the shapes
we are looking for Anna had a very great
presentation earlier where she was
bending and twisting elements to get
those awesome 2D or 3D shapes but the
limitation we have with this is that
these are only illusions of shapes or
representations of shapes because they
have no effect over the layout of their
content on the page so with this problem
in mind I would like to introduce you to
CSS shapes this is a new specification
and implementation which aims to resolve
that problem CSS shapes is a way to
Define practical reusable shapes that
can affect the content on the page and
shapes come in two shapes you have shape
inside which controls the wrapping of
the content uh within an element so you
can wrap text inside of a circle for
example um the shape inside works with a
number of functions so we can have
circles ellipses which are basically
squished circles rectangles or polygons
and then there's shape outside which
allows you to define the wrapping of the
content outside of an element so for
example we have this floated image over
here and we want the text to wrap neatly
around it so I'll just jump quickly to a
demo with shapes this is something I put
out up in one of the morning mornings I
was trying to have a nice cup of coffee
so this is using CSS shape and side for
the uh key ingredients text over there
it's wrapping the content into a uh text
the element itself is floating so we
have content flowing around it and then
we have have the image uh of the lovely
espresso Cup and the text flowing around
it as
well but Circle shapes are uh are
they're interesting but we can do more
complex shapes and this is actually the
the promise that uh aims to be fulfilled
so we can use polygons and Define very
complex shapes for our content with a a
series of points or we can use um a
source image and we can derive the shape
out of the non-transparent parts of that
image now in order to demonstrate
complex shapes I have a uh demo that I
want to show to
you we gave some thought and we we we we
thought of demonstrating to web
developers a way of enhancing visual
storytelling using CSS shapes and to do
this we uh teamed up with a awesome
agency and Paris called ultr Noir who
designed us some lovely graphics for the
uh Alice and Wonderland story now we
came and added the graphics and stitched
some CSS shapes on top of it to build an
interactive and engaging experience of
reading the Alice and Wonderland story
now this is the first time anyone
outside of adobe has seen this demo and
I'm a bit nervous because it was never
built to show on a resolution this small
but I've been tinkering with it and I
think I got it just right so this is a
graphical way of telling the Alison
Wonderland story and immediately you're
struck by the way text is being wrapped
around the shape of the tree and around
the shape of alist and this is a scroll
driven navigation so as I slowly scroll
down at one point we're going to start
moving the text with a margin top and
this is done actually outd done by the
browser and the text is going slowly
into that rabbit hole over there we're
going to slowly oh of course and it goes
back up if we scroll back up so we're
going to slowly Cross Fade to the second
scene where Alice falls through the um
uh Rabbit Hole she's a bit disoriented
and we have a bunch of mushrooms over
here and weird flowers it's apparently a
very messy rabbit and we have some uh
shape outside around that uh mushroom
over there and the text follows the um
the shape and at one point in the story
Alice reaches the um caterpillar which
with which she has a conversation we Ed
a subtle transition with CSS filters
over there and the storyboard we got
from uh ultran Noir the agency said what
if the caterpillar as she's smoking
something in the story what if her words
are actually puffs of smoke and this is
an excellent example for using CSS
regions because CSS shapes I'm sorry as
I'm scrolling uh down the content over
here I'm using a cloud shape and I'm
wrapping the text inside of it and I'm
growing that shape slowly and of course
animating it out because puffs of smoke
are lighter so there's a conversation
going on between the caterpillar analyst
here and I'm slowly scrolling so you can
get the S of course I can slow I can
scroll back down and the cater pillar is
going to in H smoke back in so this is
animating CSS shap inside on the fly so
the conversation goes on Alice is uh
very unhappy that she keeps changing
sizes and the the caterpillar which is a
very trustworthy caterpillar says H why
not eat some mushrooms because it solves
problems so she goes ahead and she eats
the mushroom and because she she does
that she meets the chire cat so I'm
actually pretty happy there was no
presentations today with cats because I
get to show the first one so this is the
a shape outside around a floated cat so
the text will go around the cat over
there but at the same time it's still
snugly fits in the um Rabbit Hole over
here and as we slowly scroll down we
have
this music we have uh multiple images of
cats as the cat is falling down and the
text is wrapping around the cat shape
and at some point the cat reaches the
ground it has a conversation with Alice
and Alice follows the cat because of
course cats are trustworthy in this
realm of
Wonderland so Alice follows through the
story we have some other shapes to
direct the attention um of the user and
at one point Alice goes to the um
Queen's garden and she plays croquet and
The Story Goes a bit like this so um as
Alice is playing there's a slow
Apparition of the chire cat with which
she has a conversation and we thought it
would be really cool to um have the cat
shape carved out into the text of the
story and to
slowly make the cat appear just like in
the real story of of Alice in Wonderland
like one year and of course by the end
the cat is grinning because she's only a
floating head and as the queen keeps
yelling off with her head there's no
head there's no body to behead the cat
from and of course because this is all a
scroll driven navigation everything
works in reverse and we get to a point
where we have a floating cat and it's
going right back up now I'm pretty happy
I have a bit more time left to show you
something really cool because while
building this demo Mo
it
initially we tried doing the shapes into
in Photoshop or in
uh an outside software program and that
proved to be a very difficult way to
work because we were basically designing
the shapes um in a software and we're
then exporting them and importing them
into the browser to see how they look
and that doesn't work well with
responsiveness so as I was trying to
rotate uh increase the phone size or
rotate the shape I would have to go back
to the software export a new shape run
it into the browser see if that works
and that's not a very fun way to spend
your workday so we came up with a pretty
interesting
solution what if we could use a
something to affect the shapes right
into the browser so we built a small
browser extension that allowed me
to let me just refresh for a
while I'm trying to make this all fit
into the screen and it
gets
difficult there you go CSS shapes so we
built a uh CSS shapes editor extension
into the browser so I'm going
to go ahead and inspect this content
over here and turn on on the shape
editor let's move that
down and this makes working
with okay that's exciting I haven't even
shown you the demo
yet so this generates a polygon by the
shape and side uh property we have over
here and it made it all the more easy to
work with the shape and edit it right in
the browser over here and instantly see
the results as I'm scrolling so for
example if I don't want
to uh move around at we can do something
like that or of course add more points
or remove more points so this is going
to I double click over here is going to
add different points so you can mess up
the shape every way you want it and this
of course works for both shape inside
and for shape outside
now this is part of the effort of
offering tooling for these awesome CSS
features and I'm pretty glad this works
because if not I would still be wasting
my time in Photoshop right now exporting
in important shapes and I wouldn't be
here so with this out of the way I can
go back to my slides and I can tell you
that CSS shapes is being implemented in
webkit and um Google Chrome and I also
listed Chrome Canary over here because
that's where the implementation is
usually uh ahead of its game from Google
Chrome the Cs CSS shapes features are
behind a chrome flag so you can enable
them and you can go ahead and play with
them now today we've looked
at more options to do responsive layout
design with CSS regions we've seen how
we can use CSS background blending to
generate textures on the fly right into
the browser and to offer much more
customization to our designs we've
looked at CSS shapes to wrap content
inside and around very complex shapes
and to break free from the clutches of
the
rectangle these are all features these
these are not prototypes these are not
experimental features these are upcoming
CSS features which developers are
actively working on and they will be
enabled in your browsers
soon I sincerely believe these are
features which can help you design more
expressive web applications and web uh
sites and I'm pretty sure Harry you're
going to have uh a much difficult time
negotiating with your designers after
these features start kicking
in if you want to learn more about them
I encourage you to go to html. adobe.com
that's where you're going to find links
to tutorials these demos and more
importantly how to enable these features
in your
browsers go ahead and get used to them
play with them experiment because
eventually you will have access to these
features and you will be able to use
them and with this I thank
you